when I got to a Seal Team when I got a
Seal Team for the first time
what guided all my decisions was wanting
to be a good seal and what makes a good
seal is a good seal supports his
teammates that's it look I don't care if
you're the best shot I don't care how
many pull-ups you can do I don't care
how good of a runner you are if you
don't look out for your teammates you're
not a good seal you won't be watered in
the teal platoon which is crazy to think
right if you have a guy that's an
unbelievable shot unbelievable diver
really good at parachuting if he doesn't
look out for his teammates no one wants
him why is that because we all know
that if we don't work together as a team
we are going to die so when you go back
you make that your priority
that I'm going to support my teammates
I'm going to support this other
department
I'm gonna do what it takes to make them
win